la onu y la cruz roja han confirmado que
ha iniciado la evacuación de un grupo de
civiles que se encontraban atrapados en
la planta de acero de mariupol en el
sureste de ucrania se trata de un
operativo muy esperado en múltiples
ocasiones se intentó evacuar a estos
civiles entre los que hay también a
niños y familias y no se había logrado
llegar al resultado de hoy que se ha
obtenido gracias a un acuerdo entre
rusia y ucrania la operación empezó el
pasado viernes y finalmente el sábado un
convoy humanitario recorrió 230
kilómetros hasta alcanzar este sitio
para trasladar a estas personas hacia
otros lugares de ucrania en los que se
puedan sentir más seguros la noticia es
sin duda un rayo de esperanza en el
medio de este conflicto que recluirse
particularmente aquí en el este del país
con combates y enfrentamientos diarios